Chris Mannix joins us the Sports
Illustrated senior writer he begins a
for City NBA podcast tour next week
beginning in Boston then he'll go
through DC Brooklyn in Philadelphia he
is at the Lakers media day today good
morning Chris
[Music]
all that that is the triumphant sound of
pain cleaning up live like a like a
young child then finally living up to
its enormous potential Ricky Rubio
somewhere is smiling you still have your
man crush on Ricky Rubio and on the
stand getting the job done yeah while
the rest of the world doesn't believe in
the World Cup Spain they come they bring
it first their stack I was wondering
this at a Laker Media Day who was the
most valuable Laker this season maybe
not the best but the most valuable I
mean I think it still has to be LeBron
right I mean he's he's the glue guy
there I mean there are you know
different types of wildcards to that
team and I think it's gonna be one of
the more interesting probably the most
interesting team to watch all season
long but you know LeBron his health his
ability to to kind of piece another team
that has what you know 50% of the roster
turned over from last season
some polarizing figures a new coach I
mean there's there's a lot of pressure
on him to put this whole thing together
in you know quickly this year but it
feels like if they're gonna win a
championship it'll be because of Anthony
Davis's contributions yeah LeBron to be
great but it feels like at some point
this Laker team stops becoming LeBrons
Laker team and it becomes Anthony
Davis's liquor team right well yes I
agree with that but it does circle back
to LeBron and his ability to kind of
allow Anthony Davis to flourish in the
way he showed in the Worland he can and
we've heard countless times Dan guys say
well I'm gonna you know take a step back
you know Davis is going to be the
leading man the thing to actually do it
and I think that's going to be a
challenge for LeBron Anthony Davis you
can certainly make a strong argument is
the best teammate he's ever had I mean I
know Dwyane Wade was great at the time
when he joined up with him but you know
ad is a bona fide MVP candidate it's
gonna be you know LeBron can have to
play off the ball more I think he's
gonna have to do some things that are
relatively new to him in his basketball
career to to make all that work I mean
you you know you say like you know they
need ad to win a championship yeah I get
killed every year talking about the
Lakers with you because I tend to be
more skeptical as I was last season but
is it not more likely that the Lakers
missed the playoffs than been the
championship I think that wait this year
right now this year you so the odds are
better that they missed the playoffs
then they win the championship I would
say so yes Wow okay I mean first of all
the they add Davis is great I think
that's stipulate to that but once again
there are more questions with this team
I'll put this way I think there are more
there's more pathways for the team to
kind of fall apart then there are for it
to come together I mean they have
enormous questions with the roster in
terms of how all these pieces fit
together they still have questions at
the point guard position
I mean Rondo is the guy right now but
can he defend that position at a high
enough level you've got Dwight Howard
injected into the mix and and I'm just
so over you know hearing Dwight Howard
talk about how he's you know gonna do
things differently this time around just
you know I liked white it just we've
heard it too many times before to
actually believe it you've got a new
coach in Frank Vogel who by by any
measure was the third choice to take
that job and and you've got LeBron
coming off a season where he had the
first significant injury of his playing
career so III think all that it creates
an atmosphere we could see this thing
goes south plus you know the Kyle Kuzma
stuff has to be a little scary I mean
stress reaction in the foot that's never
a good thing for players and the Lakers
aren't overreacting and people I talked
to in LA aren't overreacting right now
but you know when you hear foot and
stress reaction it's never a good thing
this top 100 list that ESPN put out you
know I guess you know people are up in
arms about it and LeBrons not the number
one player in the league anymore now
he's three you know Zion is ranked too
high what do you make of this list it's
all subjective I mean anyone that thinks
that LeBron should be number one hasn't
been watching basketball for the last
couple of years I mean the bran is still
a guy that can flip a switch and be
great for five minutes and better than
everybody for five minutes but you know
48 minutes I be honest clear number one
and Kawhi right behind him only because
he's probably only going to play 60 65
games in this year I mean I you nitpick
little things I looked at the list and
yeah I might have put you know Ben
Simmons a little lower karl-anthony
towns a little higher you can debate I
think I'd have Russell Westbrook or Paul
George in that listing but I mean it's
whatever it it's somebody's or a group
of people's idea of what the top 100
that's why does the same thing with
ronconi
not doing that list it's it's fine
nothing was nothing was egregious that
makes me uh you know all that upset yeah
you know people say oh it's ions ranked
ahead of clay and I went do guys realize
clay is not going to be playing the
first time for the season that's why
he's ranked higher than him he's out
till probably March so you know and at
that point you know what's he gonna look
like coming back this season you you
start this time next year I'm sure yes
right higher than Zion wins all right a
couple things we're talking to Chris
Mannix how do people get the podcast
that you're going around the country or
for City NBA podcast
yeah just hoping somebody shows up you
know that I'm not speaking to a empty
room with some of the people I have but
right now they tickets are available on
all my social media channels Twitter
Instagram Facebook all that stuff and
there'll be some stuff on that site calm
as you really ramp it up into next week
okay good the NBA is really there right
you're coming right problem
you'll try to probably get but I want
backstage passes oh yes yeah if you
really want that kind of content the NBA
is now total transparency we're gonna
find out how tall how short
some guys are why did this come about
that we need to know exactly how tall
you are
I think the NBA from from what I have
gathered well it's two things one it's
not it's the height that they're
concerned about because it becomes sort
of a goofy conversation every year
remember when you know Ben Wallace was
always listed like three inches taller
than he actually was and Kevin Durant
you know it has often insisted he not be
listed seven feet even though he
probably is 7 feet tall I just think
they just wanted to be did that
conversation be taken out of it the the
age thing though is more interesting and
we all saw what happened with Buddy
hield last year where he just kind of
miraculously got older and they just
realized he was a year older than he was
they just want all this stuff to be
accurate there's no point in them
putting it out if it's not going to be
as accurate as possible and these are
not you know getting accuracy here Dan
it's not difficult
I think you just you measure a guy you
get his accurate age and you put it out
there they don't want you know their
official website or their official
listings to be you know goofily
inaccurate well I think people are gonna
be surprised as Ione Williamson's height
yeah I agree what do I think six five
six six I'm gonna say you know that I
saw him on campus at ESPN when I was up
there a couple of weeks ago and I'm
six-three
I'm gonna guess he's he might be six six
maybe six but he's not like you know
people I think are looking at him like
he's six eight and you're right about
Durant never wanting to be listed as a
seven footer Kevin girl Garnett didn't
want to be listed as a seven footer Bill
Walton never wanted to be listed as a
seven footer it feels like if you're
gonna fit somebody into the prototypical
height for a forward or a guard like you
have to be 6-3 or you know Durant is six
nine he's seven feet at least and Walton
was probably 7 to Garnett was obviously
a 7 footer so it's interesting that
we've had you know
Berkeley was probably six four and a
half right you know you know I think
people are gonna be surprised at a
couple of these these Heights and I
don't think it matter
if that's really in today's NBA you know
ten years ago maybe 20 years ago you
know if a guard wasn't six foot four or
above you're like you got scared about
it right you didn't want to draft him
because he was too small or the same
thing with centers you know positions
fit into a certain slot when it came to
size nowadays you know teams will
regularly trot out there you know
lineups with five guys six six and under
it doesn't matter versatility remember
when tweener used to be a bad word like
you hate it too like all guys a tweener
we can't draft him now everybody wants
versatility at different positions so
it's just the way the game has changed I
just think the NBA doesn't want you know
beef types of conversations taking place
every single year I'll leave you with
this the G League with their new free
throw rule that if you get fouled on a
three-point shot you shoot one free
throw and it'll count as three and if
you are shooting a two-point shot it'll
you shoot one free throw no count as two
they want to speed up the game who goes
to a G League game and goes god I wish
this would speed up a little bit or I
wish this would be over soon I mean a G
League game I go to and wish it it could
be over soon I've been to a few of them
they're sometimes not the best product
out there in the video I think you know
the NBA has got some good rules they
experiment with in the jeely some of
which have been implemented in the NBA
this is not one of them this is this is
just dumb AJ I like the idea of a guy
need to make two free throws to tie a
game or two free throws to win a game or
three for that matter I just think it it
takes away some of the suspense all the
shave you know two or three minutes
maybe four minutes off the end and
timing of a game and the NBA are here to
dress this right like they they reduce
the time at halftime they cut away two
of those timeouts from teams they sped
up the game in the last couple of years
they have this fixation some people do
in the league office of getting to that
two hour mark per NBA game they want
really differentiate themselves I think
from baseball in that sense baseball's
interminably long NBA they want to be a
faster game that's fine but this is
stupid
like this is the kind of thing that I
don't think we'll ever get implement in
the NBA because it's just gonna look
goofy being implementing the Gigli
hey safe travels always great to catch
up with you Chris hope to see you in the
man cave here I'd say something you in
Spanish right now Dan but I don't want
to butcher the four language I have too
much respect for my Spanish brethren
thank you Chris that's Chris Mannix who
still has a man crush on Ricky Rubio for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]